he is my buddy from the nfl media group
he will be in las vegas nevada
calling the action for the los angeles
chargers radio network locally here
um as he does every single week and uh
he's at move the sticks on twitter and
uh and he and bucky brooks have a
terrific podcast for the nfl media group
he is my friend daniel jeremiah how you
doing dj
i'm doing great rich i got to tell you i
missed uh i missed last week's game as
as a lot of people have have had the
same thing i did a little about with
covid last week it was super easy i
fortunately didn't have any symptoms so
i was i was fine but i did miss the
charger game and i did get a text
message from chargers general manager
tom telesco i believe yesterday which
said hope you're feeling better uh you
better get ready we've got musburger
this week so
it's must burger week for you
jackpot baby
yeah yeah
look i feel like if this came if it got
physical up there i feel like matt money
smith's gotta got a pretty good shot
with musburger i could be in trouble
with lincoln kennedy though so that that
might not end well dude
you never heard of jimmy the greek come
on you don't want a piece of brent come
on now
come on now
it's history this man has history you
know what a piece of brent nobody wants
a piece of bread baby i i'll tell you
what maybe i don't want to be looking
live
no you don't
just ask eminem you're even
[Laughter]
okay it looks like waller's coming back
for this game huh for the raiders that
would be gonna be fun man right
so break it down for me how's this
coming for you do you think well it's
going to be a great matchup man you go
back and look at that first meeting um
it kind of was
a little bit surprising because coming
into that game the chargers hadn't
stopped the run uh you the raiders you
knew were going to run the ball and the
chargers you had this high flying
passing attack then you get out through
the game it was a weird game if you
remember remember there was the delay
um they come out in the field and they
got to go back in it was delayed by an
hour and then the chargers come out
there and run the ball down their
throats i think they ran for almost 170
yards austin eckler had 117 yards i
believe in that game
and really just kind of controlled the
line of scrimmage the raider did not run
the ball well at all um and then joey
bosa
officially graduated uh leatherwood from
tackle to guard
in that game
and so that that was just kind of a it
was a it was a weird game and now you
look at what the raiders have done it's
so impressive that they put themselves
in this position after all that's gone
on there um i think you got to give our
buddy mike a lot of credit you got to
give versace a lot of credit uh to have
them in this position and they're
playing really well hunter renfro's
is outstanding um they uh you know
they're playing better along the
offensive line their defensive fronts
playing really well and now you get
waller back so
for my money um waller and derwin james
is as fun a matchup as we get to see
yeah in the nfl that is right no
question about it
what's what's your evaluation to herbert
here i mean i had brandon staley on
yesterday and try to ask him about
um you know what he's seen and how he's
dealt with his second year
and i know his numbers are terrific but
there are games where
herbert just looks a little bit to be
very honest with you daniel lost it it
looks like the offenses
is um inconsistent at times this year
for a kid that should be lighting it up
uh even more than he does i don't know
if that's fair or not i'll give it to
you you've seen more of charger football
uh in person than i've heard it on the
radio
from you yeah well i mean
look there's been a couple hiccups you
know you look at the raven's team where
they just really struggled to move the
football patriots game the patriots game
too patriots the patriots have you know
kind of befuddled the chargers for two
years um in that game i want to say that
they moved the ball pretty well the
texans game is one um that i think
everybody's having a tough time figuring
that out when even though you look at
all the guys you're missing the texans
are missing a bunch of guys as well you
can't you just can't lose that football
game and in that one
they moved it up and down the field they
just could not you know finish some
early drives and settle for field goals
so
you know i don't think he's had i mean
gosh the guy for his second year where
he's where he is and what he's done is
is pretty incredible but you know
there's been there's been a couple you'd
like to have back i think that's just
normal you know kind of growing pains
for a young quarterback but i know when
he's locked in rich and he's at his best
um it's it's pretty it's pretty special
it's pretty fun to watch and i i know
this kid you know going back to college
think about the rose bowl he's been
pretty good in those big in those big
spots and this will be the biggest one
of his career coming up on sunday night
well i'll tell you what man uh if the
chargers win it there is a terrific
possibility of herbert at barrow for a
playoff game i mean i wouldn't i mean
you might get you might get herbert
mahomes uh number three which the first
two games have been unbelievable that's
true
um there's nothing uh nothing wrong with
that i know it's it's funny when you
kind of look at these matchups
and you look at it in first blushing i
think if it if it ended today i think
they would go to kansas city and you go
oh man the chiefs that's a tough one you
know i don't know you know how good do
you feel about that then you go what's
the alternative well you know cincinnati
well who's hotter than them right now
you got there's no easy one you know
once you get into this point of the year
so you got to go through all those teams
i think the one team ironically
um that the chargers would would
match up the worst against is the
patriots so i think from their
standpoint the bills you know taking a
hold of that division was was good news
because if you do get into the
tournament you wouldn't see the patriots
until a little later on well brockman tj
you guys just heard
the difference between dj and mayok in
terms of me having an honor conversation
with these guys in terms of evaluating
if i'd
clearly i was off the mark in my uh
question about herbert clearly
mayok would have torn me to pieces
probably daniel you that was a very
gentle very
very gentle velvet way of saying i was
wrong that this
some of the inconsistency is is part of
of of of an nfl season and and then you
moved on um i appreciate it
it's a long year i am uh i use kid
gloves but i'm gonna be honest there is
a little ulterior motivate of motivation
for me because before i came on i did
hear something about a rich eisen
trucker hat that has yet to be in my
possession okay so i'm going to be a
gentle i'm going to be very gentle
yes it's rich eisen show logo on the
front party in the back is the way we're
describing the rich eisen show trucker
hat yeah that's it right there it is up
on the screen for everyone to see and go
get it right
i've got my mug which i uh
may or may not have been given
as we say in our promo for rich
eisenshop.com it's get the mug that uh
celebrities come on and five-finger
discount for themselves so if you did
that that's entirely fine uh daniel
jeremiah here
i might have blamed it on out of pali
but i i that was me very good
daniel jeremiah here on the rich eisen
show uh
okay so um
what's how do we evaluate trevor
lawrence's first year do we
how do you how do we do this right now i
don't know it's not been good i mean
um
the problem is rich to get a fair
evaluation of any of these young
quarterbacks um i i really go back to
the three p's right you've got to have
the right play caller you've got to have
some protection you've got to have some
play makers he's old for three he
doesn't have any of that support system
that you need to be able to you know
properly evaluate him so
i don't know what you read into it i
think it's been what two touchdown
passes since halloween
which is pretty incredible uh when you
look at the the talent that he possesses
but
they have got a lot of work uh to do
there in the offseason to try and
support this kid i mean he was
wasn't just me or you know any of the
draft mix that they were high on this
kid the whole league was excited about
trevor lawrence and and believes in this
kid but man that was a
that was a rough introduction into the
nfl so you can't evaluate him is what
you're saying there's no way to evaluate
him because
you know because urban
and it was such a dumpster fire with him
there and then the cupboard was already
bare
and i guess who are the playmakers um
you know
they got her playmaker was playing
defense and returning kicks for the
detroit lion
agnew right
yeah yeah
right well and they also use the first
round pick on atn he got hurt
right yeah um james robinson i i mean he
was he was
the way they handled him this year is a
total mystery
okay so so you can't so so then after
mack jones clearly
ranked ranked the the seasons for the
rookie quarterback class
for me
well you know i i think it was so up and
down for the rest of those guys it's a
little bit hard to slot them and i'm
fired up for trey lance to be honest i
mean i know uh
we didn't play much but we just saw the
other day i think you can kind of see
the makings of of what he's going to be
like what what is that give me give me
the two cents
he's going to be he's going to provide
explosive plays in the past game and his
impact in the run game is not just going
to be felt with what he does with the
ball in his hands it's the impact of
having to account for him uh which is
going to help the rest of the guys in
the run game so i i just think it's a
it's a really really good fit there and
once he kind of gets more comfortable in
that system and that offense you'll see
it open up more but i thought you saw
glimpses of it i mean it was explosive
plays down the field the pass game now
you're going to live with some missed
some misfires underneath um but there's
going to be a bunch of big plays and
then you're going to sprinkle him in
running and then the impact of him as a
runner is going to help
with the rest of the run game so i'm a
big believer in trey lance i i've got to
be honest i thought in watching the tape
last week of zack wilson
i came away from that as encouraged as
i've been you know all year long i think
he's starting to slow down a little bit
um he's not he's getting a little bit
better protection which helps but you're
in a game rich where you don't have your
you know hasn't had left tackle the
whole year right his backup who's played
well and george fan goes out early in
that game your top two running backs are
out your top three receivers are out and
he's out there and he's got them in a
position to uh you know to beat the
tampa bay buccaneers so
i'm excited about him as well i think
this is a huge offseason they've got a
ton of picks they've got a ton of money
um i think they've got a chance finally
hopefully to get your jets um turned
around and then you know we go to you
know talk about unfair evaluations with
fields
i mean he's in and out of the lineup the
team's not very good uh you know you see
some flashes of
of what he can do there i'm excited
about him but again to rank them as darn
near impossible because of the
situations these guys around i'm i i've
got to throw davis mills in there too
right i mean the kids oh yeah no davis
mills has been davis mills has been the
second best behind mac jones if you're
looking at performance this year
when i saw it up close and personal he
he has played the second best behind mac
jones he is very under control um it
doesn't look big for him at all he can
he can do everything you want to do make
every throw
to me i was talking to me the other day
about davis i said you know what he's
going to be i think he's going to have
like a kirk cousins type career where i
think he'll probably settle in as a you
know 13 to 16 you know quarterback in
the league where he can win a lot of
games and you might be looking over his
shoulder trying to find the next guy but
it's just hard you're gonna have a hard
time finding an upgrade few more minutes
left with daniel jeremiah here on the
rich eisen show the talent evaluation
community that's about to convene in
mobile alabama and kick everything off
uh
with uh some
some some games uh of some prospects and
then we all know combine around the
corner what with your early ground and
your connection to this community was
the conversation surrounding matt
corral's decision to play can he pick
its decision to not play their love of
football
so on and so forth daniel jeremiah
i can tell you you get
uh oh it was really cool that matt
corral was going to play in the game
follow-up question does that impact your
evaluation no
uh kenny pickett not playing in the game
yeah i wish you would have played does
that impact your evaluation or opinion
of him no um they're very they're very
brief conversations in that regard these
guys have uh the haze in the barn they
put everything out there um to evaluate
them and whether they do or don't play
in that game really has no you know
bearing on on where they'll go on the
draft i i go back to that one year where
you know christian mccaffrey didn't play
and still still goes where he goes in
the top 10 didn't impact him in that
same game solomon thomas does play plays
his you know butt off and helped himself
and launched himself into the top five
so you kind of see the benefits of
playing but i i don't know that there's
really detriments not playing so there's
no conversation about love of football
nothing like that no
no i don't i think that i think that
conversation left the room a long time
ago
um and it sure as heck should have this
year when you when you look at what we
came off of last year and you look at
the best rookies in the nfl and jamar
chase rashaan slater and micah parsons
who had a whole year of no football and
i think it worked out quite well for
those three teams yeah and lance pretty
much had one too right with the
exception of one game exactly so no i i
don't i think that's i think that's
something that people in the media like
to um
uh lob around and think that these these
discussions and then there's these 80
year old scouts and rooms shaking their
fists and frustration and
i just you know i i don't think that
really happened well i mean you know in
a way you know when i heard because you
know obviously i'm referring to what uh
kirk curve street and um and and desmond
howard were saying on espn prior to the
rose bowl that caught a lot of fire i
mean i i totally and you and i feel
similarly sometimes when we hear
somebody's not going to spin it at the
combine because that's our broadcast
right like that's our world and we wish
they would but when it all comes down to
it there's no
there's no red flag or evaluation that
comes from that is there like no either
i mean i think does that go back i want
to say i'm trying to think back to the
first time somebody didn't throw is that
andrew luck maybe i think that could
even predate that too
dj i'll be honest with you uh i don't
think did eli throw at the comments yeah
you know what you're not i mean that i
don't think eli did right i don't know i
don't know if he did either so
no but i i you know what i'm i'm anxious
instead of instead of us and not talking
about you and me but you know obviously
we want to see these guys throw because
it's fun and uh it makes for a much
better broadcast but instead of
you know the community kind of
complaining about these guys not
throwing why don't we do something on
our end to incentivize them to throw um
and whether that's a combination of cash
and rich eyes and trucker hats i don't
know but there's got to be something we
can do
i appreciate you pushing putting rich
eisen trucker hats on par with actual
cold hard american cash daniel i i
appreciate you combine it with the price
is right and have him play plinko or
something
well i mean can you
can you imagine though how much fun it
would be if we said all right for each
position group whoever has the fastest
40s well
thousand dollars if uh why not i mean
come on daniel you know
uh i'm all for having guys run 40s next
to each other you know and i i'm all for
turning it into a full-on competition
but the scouting community wouldn't they
blanch at it or no well
who cares
they're gonna complain they're gonna you
know they complain when it when it's
spread out over a couple extra days i'm
gonna be honest i mean the rams less
less has kind of set the bar on that one
where they don't really bring many guys
to indy they sit home and watch it on tv
like the rest that's because they don't
have draft choices anymore daniel
where's that there's that no they own
the third round
that's um that's right
but i mean look i i think teams are not
bringing quite as many personnel as they
used to there but let's let's kind of
embrace this thing i mean
these teams are getting all the gps
numbers on these kids right from college
so they have a pretty good idea of how
fast and how fast they are and all that
stuff already but i just think man let's
let's blow it out man let's have some
fun so full circle like uh uh wilson and
olave not playing in the rose bowl and
pickett not playing you know in the
peach bowl and corral playing uh in the
sugar bowl and getting hurt their
evaluations are going to be the same
when it comes down to seeing them at the
combine getting them on a grease board
interviewing them and seeing their pro
day
that will not be affected based on what
just happened in the bowl season is what
you're saying that
that will not now there there might be
uh
it might sit in a room and get an
uncomfortable question from a grumpy
coach or a grumpy scout but
at the end of the day the people who are
making those decisions and stacking that
board
that's not going to have any impact
whatsoever
last thing for you daniel the fact that
antonio brown is still on the bucks
roster uh florio and others are saying
it's because the bucks are afraid
somebody else might take him and use him
against them
in a playoff run or maybe even in the
super bowl are our teams
would you really believe an nfl team
after
the burning of the steelers raiders
patriots and now bucks
um would would say the fifth time will
be different
well you just he's running out of teams
i mean first of all i mean that there's
limiting options because he's burned so
many of those bridges i i don't
i can't imagine at this point in time
the teams that are in the tournament are
getting ready to be in the tournament um
that they want to bring in somebody like
that to completely rock the boat of
what's been you know obviously a
successful season if you're getting your
way into the playoffs i just
i cannot imagine that anybody would do
that that would i would be floored i
would be completely shocked if that were
to take place and has has a player ever
been caught on the sideline that you
know of like that just basically like
you're done
during a game no i was that uh i was
calling the chargers bills game
um when uh cam who was the corn the
corner he quit at halftime
uh for the bills oh that's right
he said yeah
okay yeah and he left at halftime
correct left it happened yeah we're
watching the second half when i go uh
i'm looking at money i'm like what
happened to him he's not out he's not
out there anymore he gets this muscle
got hurt or maybe he's got an upset
stomach or something and then after the
game i ran into i was down in the tunnel
after the game was overweight for the
bus and i ran into one of the bills
players that i knew going through the
draft process with ivante davis is that
what it was
i said hey she's curious like what
happened to vontae davis he goes oh he
quit i go at halftime he goes yeah no he
left the stadium at halftime to quit but
i just wow i never seen that one right
but at least he just left he didn't take
off his uniform and stripped down and
throw and wave goodbye to the crowd and
run you know during a play during a game
during a moment you know what i'm saying
and and
it just i i don't know man it just kind
of surprises me or then and then
depresses me because it doesn't surprise
me that another team might actually take
a shot at him after all
gosh that would be
i don't i just can't see it man maybe i
think josina came out the other day and
said she knows a team that would
would be interested in signing him i
just i can't imagine how you how you get
that up the chain to your owner to sign
off on that that just seems crazy to me
daniel jeremiah i appreciate the time
let's chat uh in the next couple weeks
as well uh have a great time in vegas
say hi to brent for me don't go don't go
full anchorman in fisticuffs okay just
don't do it
don't do it yeah no i'll bring my anvil
it'll be good next time i see you i'll
have a trucker hat for you
oh yes now we're talking you just gotta
post it you gotta you're an influencer
don't forget so you know don't forget
you gotta influence people all right
there you go daniel jeremiah everybody
round of applause on the mercedes-benz
van hey buddy phone line right here on
the rich eisen show nice little golf
clap for dj hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that watch more
right here